1996 年
比爾蓋茲上了 David Letterman 的深夜節目
Letterman 問他
電腦還會不會有我們現在想不到的下一步
我們現在做的，多半是把電腦當成工具
幫我們學習，或是找到興趣相同的人
也許有一天，我們會想出怎麼讓電腦思考
但那其實是非常難的問題
事實上，這方面幾乎毫無進展
所以沒人知道什麼時候會發生，有人覺得永遠不會
我們也不希望它們會思考吧？
我想不太希望
想起來滿可怕的
那是 30 年前
這兩個禮拜
比爾蓋茲至少上了四個節目
一直在敲 AI 的警鐘
這一集我們把其中三場剪在一起
9 月 15 號泰晤士報的 podcast
9 月 27 號 NBC 的《Meet the Press》
還有 9 月 29 號紐約時報的 Ezra Klein 訪談
每一段是哪一場，我們都會先講
剛剛那段 Letterman
就是 Ezra 在訪談一開頭放給他看的
接著問他，從那時候到今天
中間發生了什麼
我那時常去 OpenAI，看他們在做什麼
我出了一道題給他們：如果你能讀完生物課本，考過 AP 大學先修考試
而且拿滿分，也就是 5 分
那你就證明了你真的讀得懂，能把知識變成拿得出來用的形式
結果在公開發表前 6 個月，Sam、Greg 跟 Ilya 來了
在我家當場示範，AP 考試考到 5 分
就連我自己出的、它不可能看過的題目，非常複雜的生物題
它也幾乎全對
那是第一次震撼
第二次震撼
我們換到 9 月 15 號泰晤士報那場來聽
然後，差不多等級的經驗是在去年底
特別是 Claude 寫程式的能力，現在不只 Claude
在很多方面超過了我自己寫程式的能力
對我來說就是：「天啊，這是大事」
因為那代表，網攻風險跟生物風險的門檻到了
所以我以為：「好，大家都會跑來討論這件事了」
因為這些門檻到了，我們一直知道它們會來
但我得說，連我自己都以為會晚一點才來
回到 9 月 29 號 Ezra Klein 那場
我之前…我上週訪問了輝達的黃仁勳
他說，他認為安全確實是個問題，但競賽這件事是假的
產品不安全，就別發布
這是…我們不需要新的法律
產品還沒準備好就不發布，這是每個 CEO 自己的責任
你怎麼看？
從來沒有一個產品，大家對它的能力理解得比 AI 還少
AI 已經跨過門檻，它能讓生物恐怖分子殺掉數億人，這今天就存在
能發動網路攻擊，把所有銀行帳戶弄亂、讓電網停擺，這今天就存在
我們知道這是事實
會這樣，是因為心懷惡意的人可以拿 AI 去做這些事
不是未來某一天，AI 的那種控制問題
也就是 AI 自己誤解了要最佳化的目標，跑去做壞事
我們今年初就已經跨過網攻的門檻，也跨過了生物的門檻
Ezra 接著替黃仁勳那一邊問
出了事，公司自己就會被告
市場的誘因還不夠嗎
我簡直不敢相信你會問這個
這是人類碰過最危險的東西
在別的領域，我們會說「藥儘管上市，沒有 FDA」嗎？
「也沒有飛安委員會，車子也不用裝安全帶」
我們只靠責任法來保護大家的安全嗎？
「喔，你在賣鴉片類藥物，那就等人來告你」
我們建立的社會，是想辦法讓大家安全
不是說「喔，我們可以讓做這件事的人破產」
這裡的傷害…你說有過濾，根本沒有過濾
你可以拿一個能做生物武器的開源模型，把所有監控都拿掉，這今天就存在
所以沒有，根本沒有任何過濾
死了 1 億人，你要打官司？我都快笑出來了
這不是我的看法，但這是川普總統的看法，某種程度上也是 David Sacks 的看法
也是黃仁勳的看法，所以我才拿它來問你
因為這就是美國此刻的主流看法
不，可以這樣說：業界以外，大家對 AI 危險的認識非常低
學術界是這樣，智庫是這樣，制定政策的人、政治人物也是
我會講得這麼大聲，能多大聲就多大聲
有一部分原因是，這件事不能靠業界自律。那根本是瘋了
我心裡唯一的問題是：我們要等到網路攻擊、生物攻擊都造成大災難
才規定這些模型要裝監控防護，免得同樣的事一再發生
還是我們夠聰明，在死掉幾百萬人之前，就把這些裝進去、規定一定要裝
你剛寫了這篇談 AI 風險的文章，聽起來你的警覺程度跳了一大級，對吧？
我讀了你以前的幾篇文章
2023 年 7 月那篇的標題是〈AI 的風險是真的，但可控〉
這次我覺得，你講的威脅是另一個等級
所以照你剛剛說的，我的理解是
你是看到生物、網攻、寫程式這些能力在進步，這樣說對嗎？
不是。重點是，我們一直說，跨過這些門檻的時候，要動員全社會
因為到那時，我們已經造出了史上最危險的東西
這讓核武看起來像沒什麼
我們說過要動員，結果門檻跨過了，一片沉默
大家討論的是業界誰說了這個、誰又說了那個
但學術界、智庫有多少比例……
所以是完全沒有回應
9 月 27 號
他上了 NBC 的《Meet the Press》
主持人問得更直接
你認為 AI 強到可以終結全人類嗎？
AI 絕對強到可以引發造成 10 億人死亡的事件
所以，就算要到 100% 很難
也從來沒有一種武器，比心懷惡意的人加上最新的 AI 工具更強大
業界幾乎是違背自己的利益在承認這些事，有這樣的討論是好事
也有人在討論關機鍵
關機鍵做得到嗎？在這個階段實際嗎？
關機鍵…那是個有點怪的東西
光有關機鍵是不夠的
它們…我們還沒到它們會自己搶電腦、關都關不掉的地步
所以那個討論，只是顯示很多人有多不懂技術
我不會說我反對關機鍵
但你不…你要管住壞行為，就得看得到它在做什麼，還要有紀錄
所以光靠關機鍵，擋不了這些悲劇
你也知道，川普總統最近發文說
「AI 接管世界、毀滅人類，還有其他一切壞事，都是騙局」
你覺得這些說 AI 可能威脅人類存亡的警告，是騙局嗎？
不，這完全不是騙局
但他一開始這樣反應，不代表他不會聽
他想保護美國人民
大部分人不懂 AI 現在發生了什麼，他們沒在用最新的模型
AI 要各國一起管，總得有人帶頭
回到 9 月 15 號泰晤士報那場
但你覺得，大概還是要由美國帶頭？
那一直是主要的模式
世界其他國家還不習慣美國不出來領導
疫情的時候我們就看到了
現在的 WHO 裡，剛好沒有美國
所以，世界還沒完全適應，美國不在場、不去處理那些最尖端問題的情況
回到 9 月 29 號 Ezra Klein 那場
還有一大段在講工作
Ezra 問他，放射科醫師沒有少
工程師也還是很搶手
為什麼你認為 AI 真的會大規模搶走工作
對。毫無疑問，到目前為止，AI 創造的工作比毀掉的多
光是蓋資料中心，需要的人手就非常多
失業率也算低
但這些系統要勝出，得先跨過一個門檻：你得相信它非常可靠
如果你要讓電話銷售、電話客服改用 AI
你得確定它比人更準確
到現在，真正跨過這個門檻的職業只有寫程式
就算在這一行，我也認識很多人有點停在過去，不想用 AI 寫程式
但管工程師的主管都懂，大部分應用程式現在都能用很低的成本做出來
接下來幾年，會計、法律工作、電話銷售、電話客服，都會跨過那些門檻
很多人拿 Jevons 悖論反駁他
東西變便宜，需求就會變多
工作最後會長回來
一旦整個任務都能交給它做，有沒有需求彈性就不重要了
那筆錢會進 token 預算，不會進人的薪水預算
有些事情用 AI 做的成本，比人力低太多了
所以一旦跨過可靠度的門檻，不管是白領，還是人形機器人
工作就會消失，而且沒有高地可以退
以前的創新是這樣：有了曳引機，沒關係
那就去蓋迪士尼樂園，雇很多人
現在整個經濟裡，沒有那種地方了
說工作會淨增加的人，我不懂他們在想什麼
他們一定不了解現在進步的速度
美國的製造業就業，並沒有出現 Jevons 悖論，對吧？
我們的產量暴增，但很多工作移到了海外
有些工作被自動化取代
但美國現在的總就業人數，並沒有比 1960 年少
原因是大家轉去做服務業
整個經濟的工作組成變了
對，人的腦力變成稀缺的東西。重點永遠是稀缺
一旦人的腦力不再稀缺，事實上是被遠遠甩開
它 24 小時工作、讀得更多、懂每一種語言
就沒有更上一層的稀缺，可以讓你往上移了
所以你覺得，人類不會剩下任何稀缺的東西？
你說一個出來
所以你對這件事的答案，帶出了你一個很具體的主張
就是對 AI 的使用課稅。為什麼？怎麼課？
這樣說吧，勞工是隨收隨付，把錢繳進退休金、社會安全基金
所以是在職的人在養退休的人
如果你解雇了一個人，找機器人來做那份工作
為什麼要這麼鼓勵拿掉人力，卻不讓機器人也繳退休金？
怎麼回事？難道是挺機器人的工會，把稅法改成
「不是血肉之軀就不用繳，讓退休金破產吧」？
就算沒有機器人取代，退休金本來也在往破產走
他另一個提議，是事先把托育
長照這類工作劃出來，保留給人做
他叫它「人類保留職業」
Ezra 說
你對工作比很多實驗室裡的人還悲觀
他講了一個故事
主角是 Amazon 找真人做零碎小工作的平台 Mechanical Turk
好笑的是，我跟一個被很多人當成研究 AI 的首席經濟學家講這些
他說：「那 Mechanical Turk 怎麼還在？如果 AI 真的像你說的那麼強，Amazon 怎麼還經營得下去？」
我說：「它不會在了。」一週後，它就完全關掉了
而且，知識這樣擴散開來…你不得不說
不覺得很驚人嗎？知道得越多，就越擔心
9 月 27 號 NBC 那場的最後
主持人問他，希望他的孩子跟孫子
未來是什麼樣子
所以，跟孩子說要用對的方式用 AI、去追自己好奇的東西
這個建議現在還是對的
但因為接下來的變化太劇烈
我預測 10 年後世界長什麼樣子的能力，比我這輩子任何時候都差
這是一場演化等級的事件：一種外來的智慧，不是搭太空船來的
是從這些電腦裡來的。它已經在這裡了，而且進步的速度快到不可思議
1996 年他說
讓電腦思考幾乎毫無進展
30 年後
他一個節目接一個節目地講
要大家趕在大災難之前
先把防護跟監控裝進每一個 AI
三場訪談加起來兩個多小時
泰晤士報那場
他還回答了 AI 是不是泡沫
Ezra 那場
則講了 AI 會怎麼影響小孩的學習
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。